people keep asking why you gotta be
queer prom and I say I'm not going to
name it prom that happens to have tons
of gay people there so we are centering
tonight on us for once right
[Music]
we got a few speakers for you tonight
and the Kenneth Palmer was an intern at
the It Gets Better Project when I was in
high school I came out my junior year
and I looked around at a school that
didn't really accept LGBTQ young people
I became the president of my high
school's GSA which is the Gay Straight
Alliance and I had so many amazing
experiences in that classroom you know
every week is where we could be
ourselves where we could laugh and talk
about queer topics and what my message
is to all of you is because you're queer
maybe you aren't normal you're different
and you know what that's not only okay
that's perfect you're perfect the way
you are you have a very special prom
courts that was flown in from across the
nation come up on the stage we have a
special guest who's going to be
anointing you King Queen or anything in
between
can we get Adam Lambert to the stage
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
ah you guys are so good I know when I
was in high school I I'm gonna say it it
was I graduated in the year 2000 I just
said it I said it we didn't you know
life was different for to be LGBT or Q
in America it was entirely different I
think the only thing I had was willing
Grace on TV that was it so it was a lot
of jokes watching as an adult over the
years watching things change it's been
unbelievable to see how people are
becoming exactly who they want to be
earlier they're they're sure of it
they're they're able and they're given
the permission in certain places to
explore I can't believe how fast we're
progressing and I know we have a lot of
work to do still with equality but man
it's really exciting to watch that the
growth that's happened here in America
and around the world this is your 2017
BuzzFeed queer prom courts you might
know one of the most brilliant actresses
of her generation a little show called
West world where there's proof in the
pudding when her character finally gets
to wear pants she shoots [ __ ]
up so give it up for BuzzFeed's queer
prom queen Evan Rachel Wood now this is
amazing my dreams are coming true in so
many ways I'm so happy I'm happy beyond
all reason to be here tonight and then I
look at you guys and I see progress and
it just makes me so happy to know that
we can all come together on a night like
this because we're family when I'm with
people in large groups like this but
that I relate to so much I hold on to
that feeling and even when you're
feeling alone remember this feeling and
remember your family because we're
always there with you and you're never
alone
ever I also wear a little unicorn around
my neck and it's not just because I'm
bisexual it's because I grew up feeling
like like the black sheep and I'm
feeling weird and strange and like there
was something wrong with me and then I
realized as I got older I was not a
black sheep I was a unicorn I was a rare
mythical creature
and I was special because I was
different and I embraced that and so
just remember you're not a black sheep
you're a unicorn
always in forever we can't end a
crowning ceremony without a very special
tradition from a very beautiful man
can I get Daniel friends say say onto
the stage please
[Applause]
she totally goes here I can't tell you
how beautiful it is to see all of these
rainbow colors in this room and all of
these rainbow people my mom one of her
students said why is it dime worth more
than a nickel if a dime is smaller and a
nickel is bigger and heavier and even
though it isn't logical it wasn't
logical that I went to prom with a girl
and didn't really get to go with someone
that I cared about and it perhaps wasn't
logical that Damien and Mean Girls that
ended up alone at the Spring Fling but
now I'm not the shy closeted queer kid
at the prom I'm here with my fiance
Joseph okay so remember even when the
world isn't logical just still be
yourself and shine as bright as all of
the colors in our rainbow now they want
to give me this crown but since it's
about breaking rules at the queer prom
I'm just gonna break this I read it all
these dreams
everyone here is a king a queen or
something in the tree
[Music]
you